we had a caller last week a fella that
called any young buck and he was having
issues he was doing dominoes in
delivering um hot pie and we've all had
it you know we've all had a little bit
of Domino's and oh and one thing I don't
know if you knew this about Domino's
somebody sent me this DM the other day
and told me this but Domino's Pizza used
to have a character called the know Wade
and that's not a racial slur or anything
that's a it's like a cartoon it was like
a dirty cartoon boy that you know was
sneaky and was kind of a tag and I got I
think he wanted to be Italian it was
like a wannabe Italian and he would
attack um he hit on the commercial for
Domino's this character the no Wade NO
ID and again that's not any type of a
race thing and as a that's what they
called him he would attack the delivery
people or something he would mess up the
order and so the pizza was going to get
there late but Domino's they said that
we guarantee that won't happen your
pizza will be there in 30 minutes and
you got to understand this was
unprecedented for somebody to say from
the time you call our shop 30 minutes
later we're gonna have food at your
doorstep Dawg that's gangster dawg post
my son even guarantee that [ __ ] post
makes don't get post may say could be
now could be 70 minutes dude I had a
lady one time she was driving her over
got hit got an accident got taken off an
ambulance my [ __ ] said like three hours
because she been at the hospital for so
long everybody had gone up to three
hours this lady had not dropped off my
Carl's juniors and this I don't know if
she died or what bro but that [ __ ] you
know I mean it's a risky game out there
when you peddling goods like that but
let me tell you about this the no wait
was this little character and it was big
he had a video game he had big stuff and
dominoes blew it up at that moment they
had pizza in 30 minutes
so the noid though there was a guy let
me tell you what happened so then no
wait here's what happened on January
30th 1989
Kenneth Lamar noid a mentally ill man
who thought the ad campaign was a
personal attack on him entered a
Domino's restaurant in chamblee Georgia
armed with a 357 gang bruh
so you know the [ __ ] on him well and
he held two employees hostage for over
five hours can you imagine that affect
you first of all you freaking working at
Domino's and his second of all the dude
rolls over the 357 and held you hostage
actually probably it's probably best cuz
you're still on the clock and you don't
you can't make any pies I mean I guess
you could but the guy might get pissed I
guess it's up to him it doesn't say if
he ordered any pies around it just says
he held two employees hostage for over
five hours after telling the employees
that Domino's owner Tom Monaghan had
stolen his name because his last name
was knowing n o ID he forced them to
call Domino's headquarters and demand a
hundred grand and a white limousine as
getaway transportation
what an idiot but you know how hard it
is to hide in a way in a white limousine
very hard bro unless you hide it like a
I don't know where you'd hide like in a
milk fat like in a milk area
after offering to exchange one hostage
for a copy of the widow's son which I
get a son book the noid reneged on his
offer after a police brought him the
book no it eventually became hungry and
forced the employees to make him two
special pizzas
respect man respect while annoyed ate
the pizzas with his gun in his lap the
hostages escaped
noid surrendered to the police shortly
after after the incident police chief
read Miller told reporters he's paranoid
noid was charged with kidnapping
aggravated assault doesn't say he
[ __ ] assaulted him
extortion and possession of a firearm
during a crime I wouldn't call going to
Domino's a crime that's kind of
judgmental he was found not guilty by
reason of insanity gang no we'd spent
time in a mental institution but
committed suicide in 1995 2:00 a.m. this
incident has been insinuated to have
caused Domino's Pizza to discontinue
advertising using the no wait as their
mascot Wow so there you go that's
everything that happen within no wait
and thank you to the young man has sent
me sent me a DM and told me that oh what
else man what else have I been doing
dude do it nada same thing you've been
doing good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was ok but
the next video you can watch could be
way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one